man when you look at the numbers they're
very very clear in 2019 and we'll go to
2020 so far but in 2019 there were nine
african-american people shot who are
unarmed most people can put two and two
together and realize that just because
you're unarmed don't mean you're not a
threat don't mean that it's unjustified
but for the sake of arguing just say
that all nine unarmed black males were
killed by police
unjustifiably there is 44 million black
people I have lost count of the zeros
and the percentage of you getting killed
by a police officer unjustifiably and
when you look at those numbers and then
you go and you look at the amount of
black people who get killed on a
day-to-day basis through black on black
violence and you do not see the same
level of outrage the same level of
protest we can clearly see that is some
brainwashing going on I'm Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report reminder
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and click that notification bell
and joining me today is an ex-police
officer and co-founder of the blegh zit
movement Brandon Tatum welcome back to
the Rubin report how you doing Dave man
good to see you again I'm good I'm good
thanks for joining us I know this is
last minute and you are stretched a
million ways because everything going on
right now so for the people that don't
know you we're gonna link to our
original interview down below but can
you just do like a couple minute Brandon
Tatum 101 by your childhood and what got
you into policing and then out of
policing and then we're gonna obviously
talk about everything going on right now
okay cool I grew up in Fort Worth Texas
I grew up in a split home I'm and daddy
wedding together and they didn't even
know their parents or at least their
their their fathers and so people would
project that I would have a certain
outcome in life maybe I wouldn't be
successful but see that wasn't true
God had a plan for me even though my
parents were fostering me to be the best
that they could do I ended up getting
arrested at eight years over smoking
marijuana in a vacant house and my dad
had a
very stern and strong conversation with
me after that incident which led me to
want to get into sports and want to do
the right thing
from that point moving forward All
American football player I played
college football at the University of
Arizona and after the NFL didn't work
out for me I needed a job I needed a
career I never thought about being a
police officer a day in my life and I
signed up because I needed some money I
needed a good career and I did a
ride-along with the police department
because I had to figure out what the
heck am I gonna actually do if they hire
me and after I did a ride-along it just
blew me away I was inspired for the
first time in my life I saw a hero and
officer Shawn Payne who took me on that
ride-along I started to get into
politics later in my career as a police
officer and that just led me to where
I'm at now now I'm doing things on my
own on my own business working with Ken
as long as we co-founded blex it and now
I'm on Dave Rubin for the second time
can you talk a little bit about how when
you were a police officer that you sort
of knew how to speak the language of the
people in these communities so you kind
of were a bridge between the communities
that were being policed or that needed
the policing the most and the actual
police officers because I think that'll
probably be a good segue to get us to
everything else happening right now yeah
cuz I grew up with with a lot of
exposure to a lot of things that I dealt
with as a police officer in these
communities you know I didn't grow up in
a peachy household you know my mom and
dad was separated like I said before and
my stepdad was a gang banger and he used
to use drugs and he end up dying from a
heroin overdose so some of the problems
that we dealt with in the inner city I
was exposed to him myself
and so I could speak to individuals and
for some reason and I don't know why cuz
you're still gonna go to jail the same
way but because I was black a lot of
african-american people in the
communities that I Patrol they saw I
guess a connection with me and so I was
able to be sort of the liaison or you
know a lack of better turns the black
person whisperer
they used to always get me to come to
the scene to talk and to calm down
individuals and like I said because I've
been there done that
I was able to communicate effectively
okay so as I said earlier we're gonna
link down
to their to the other interview that we
did so people can get more of your story
but let's jump into the current
situation so first off let's talk about
the incident itself and and the video
that now everybody has seen and has
millions and millions and millions of
views what happened to George Floyd from
your outsider perspective just knowing
the amount that we can know from from
video what were what went wrong did
anything go right what were the other
officers doing what are you supposed to
do as an officer in a situation like
that just just lay it all out yeah if we
had a training video to show you what
not to do as a police officer and what
not to do as responding officers this
would probably be a perfect example I
don't see or I don't have any
information of what happened before this
gentleman ended up on the ground but
what I can't tell you as a police
officer a former police officer is that
it's unacceptable to have your knee on a
man's neck for I don't know eight nine
minutes there's no reason he's
handcuffed he's on the ground you have
leverage over him and he's complaining
of having medical issues people are
recording you and you still remain in
the position that seems to be putting
this gentleman at a at a life and death
situation so as a former police officer
any rational person you should be
rendering a you should back off for the
guy and there was a concept that I said
in a video that I made on my youtube
channel as a concept of excited delirium
and a lot of people never heard of the
concept of excitedly real maybe if
you're not in law enforcement you
probably would never hear of it but
excited the lyrium is a theory that when
people are hyped up on drugs those
uppers like PCP methamphetamine it gets
your heart rate up get your adrenaline
rushing and what happens you become a
superhuman and then your body begin to
crash so you go down a path of crashing
kind of like if you drink sugar and you
get tired or sleepy afterwards but this
crash it goes and it continues until you
die and we're trained as police officers
to be able to observe that and some of
what mr. George Floyd was experiencing
seemed to be a level of excited delirium
so when when a guy is going down like
that a police officer back off
render a roll him on his side make sure
he can breathe because he could be
hyperventilating he could be having some
distress that may not be a direct
connection which Arnie on his neck and
you should know that as a police officer
so it seems to me that part of the
reaction to this one that is totally
justified is that the officer had his
hand in his pocket almost as if I'm not
even trying here I can just do whatever
I want what do you think and I know you
can't read their minds but the other
three officers that are standing there
what do you think is going on in their
minds that as they're watching this I
mean put you know where everyone's
laying blame where it should be lamed at
the officer who did this but what about
the other guys because that gets to when
people start talking about the culture
of policing yeah I don't think it's so
much of a cultural response it's of a
human nature you know the other officers
I'm assuming are waiting for the next
officer to say something and nobody ever
says anything and then I believe that
that officer seems to be somewhat of the
lead officer on the case
he's the most I guess it could be the
most experienced he's the most dominant
and so I'm assuming and I don't know if
this is what they were thinking but I've
seen this happen before is once
operational momentum gets underway there
are officers who are assuming and hoping
to God that the officer would his knee
on the guy's neck is acting in good
faith and it's not gonna kill the guy
and get everybody fired so there's a
little bit of expecting the officers to
all do their own job and expecting the
officer who who is coming across as the
leader to not kill a man in cold blood
so I think that there's a little bit of
cowardice that goes on and people in
general and I see some of that could
have probably spilled over to this law
enforcement experience with George Floyd
when you see that video do you
immediately view it through a racial
lens you know the way the media pushes
everything on us is that we have to see
this as white officer you know black man
that we have to view it purely through
that and I'm not saying we shouldn't see
it through that lens but that there are
probably several lenses
that we should see these things when you
see that how much of your reaction to it
is just viewed sewers through the racial
prism alone well Dave I never look at
things racially unless I have a reason
to so when I looked at this video I see
what I believe to be cop or police
misconduct and I see a man struggling
for his life or potentially having a
medical issue with no officers rendering
aid race never entered into my mind not
one time and unless I saw that the
officer was a clan's member or he came
out of City hate black people or
something of that nature that would have
instigated me to have that thought
process I don't even go down that road
because this pointless is
counterproductive and all it does is
create division and we can never get to
a solution anywhere anyhow because some
of the officers I think it was only one
out said it was white and that was the
officer that was using force but the
other other officers are going to be
held accountable as well they all got
fired and they were of other races so to
project and make it as is a black and
white racial tension thing is
disingenuous and it's hurtful to the
narrative and it's hurtful to us
actually getting justice where justice
is deserved yeah so okay so since I
think everyone watching this probably
agrees with that I mean any sensible
person we want justice to be served
obviously they've been taken into
custody and hopefully the system will
deal with them appropriately so we have
to shift to now what's becoming the the
bigger story here so as the guy that
co-founded blogs it with Candice Owens
it seems to me that you guys have made
just absolutely staggering amounts of
traction in terms of waking up black
people too you don't have to be a
Democrat which is just a simple fact of
the world your skin color of course
should not dictate what political party
you are so first let me just start let's
let's just start with that how is that
just connected to all of this the
narrative that we're seeing right now
that America is racist and that policing
is racist and it's systemic and that our
founding is racist how is all of that
stuff connected to why you guys wanted
to start blogs it yeah because when you
think
about it for what it is it's like we are
outraged we're a burning building down
communities protesting and rioting days
in day in and day out for what and what
I have observed and canons are like well
we have observe is that we have been
brainwashed into thinking what our
emotions and not thinking with facts man
when you look at the numbers they're
very very clear in 2019 and we'll go to
2020 so far but in 2019 there were nine
african-american people shot who are
unarmed most people can put two and two
together and realize that just because
you're unarmed don't mean you're not a
threat don't mean that it's unjustified
but for the sake of arguing just say
that all non unarmed black males were
killed by police
unjustifiably there is 44 million black
people I have lost count of the zeros in
the percentage of you getting killed by
a police officer unjustifiably and when
you look at those numbers and then you
go and you look at the amount of black
people who get killed on a day-to-day
basis through black on black violence
and you do not see the same level of
outrage the same level of protest we can
clearly see that it's some brainwashing
going on and what Candis and I want to
do
it's just outfit people with the truth
and give them an outlet to say I don't
have to just think and be ignorant just
because I'm black I can have an open
mind I can see what's really going on
some of these people live in the hood
some of these people know that they're
not afraid of the police they know that
they're afraid of gang violence and
abuse that happens in the inner-city a
lot of people know that it has something
to do with social economic status and
not just necessarily the color of your
skin and so we are pushing truth and
initially it hurts man
a lot of people hate us initially they
don't want to hear from us we [ __ ]
sellout Uncle Tom's but as time goes
along and they can see that there's a BS
narrative being pushed they can see that
that black people are destroying their
own communities that it is gotten out of
control they begin to see people like
myself or Candice who are promoting
facts and they be getting to wake up
it's simple mathematics so I got to
bring up a guy who I know you know and I
know you saw this moment when larry
elder beat me
senseless with that woke me up woke me
up to so much of this stuff right but
what do you do with a certain set of
people who don't respond to facts
because even on Twitter for the last 24
hours
I tried to take the weekend off and it
didn't work that well but just in the
last 24 hours of being on Twitter I see
the type of stuff that you are putting
out there I see the type of stuff that a
lot of conservatives are putting out
there relative to facts and numbers and
all of these things and I never see any
counter to those things generally by
people on the left I see the sort of
overly emotional you know we just we are
a racist because in and of itself it is
true it's just it's self-evident that
were a racist nation so what do you do
when a certain set of people won't
accept facts well I go with the Bible
man I mean Jesus was preaching truth in
fact and they killed him and so my thing
is that we need to just continue to
promote facts and truth and understand
that we are planting seeds not every
single person is going to turn around
every time we open our mouth and say
something but we have to be consistent
with what we know to be true just like
Jesus even though they killed him he was
raised on the third day and now he's the
most talked about person ever in history
the Bible is the most sold book in the
history of the world so we have to
continue to stick with the mission keep
her own facts and understand that we're
planting seeds and at some point those
seeds will be watered and one of the
reasons why we can do that is because
Candace and I are a product of seeds
being planted like you said Larry elder
and others planet seeds in us and then
in 2016 the perfect storm of enough
water and sunshine sprouted up seeds
that are now some of the most impactful
individuals in the black movement know I
mean it's been unbelievable just to see
this thing grow it's it's just you know
I tweeted out about a year ago in the
midst of one of these stories that
Trump's gonna get something like 30% of
the black vote and of course you know
nobody wants to be in the prediction
game and I had a lot of blue cheque
lefties really angry at me for saying it
and of course everything right now it's
like who the hell knows what's gonna
happen but I think you guys have made a
dent and whether that dent is fully
evident in this coming election or
it's the one after or the one after it
just seems obvious but but let's move to
sort of be immediacy right now because
it seems to me this is no longer about
George Floyd I mean when you're watching
people burned down stores break into
liquor shops loot the Nike store tear
down a target all of the rest of it what
what do you think the transition is from
a righteous cause of not wanting to see
in an you know someone be killed
unjustly to where we're at right now
like how many steps does that take and
do you think some of this was
pre-planned before it all began just a
couple days ago yeah I think man I think
it's a lot of people in our society that
are just as strong there's a lot of
people who didn't get parent well
there's a lot of people that just want
violence they don't want justice they
want revenge they've been brainwashed
they don't want to go to work they don't
want to work hard they don't believe in
the American Dream they hate this
country to hate themselves and those
people tend to flare up when we have
incidents like this because clearly they
are not focused on George Floyd they're
not focused on police brutality police
brutality has nothing to do with
footlocker and Louie Vuitton and Gucci
it has nothing to do with stealing and
burning down historical buildings has
nothing to do with that the man was
arrested it should be over the protest
should be over diluting the rioting the
outrage should be done with but it's not
so we need to understand that there is a
difference between individuals who are
actually wanting something to change and
then the individuals who are burning
stuff down because there are brats and
they're just menace to society and those
two parties end up clashing because
politicians and other liberal and I say
leftist black talking hands won't be
honest they're coming out saying that
it's antifa and they're in there just
completely forgetting or trying to evade
the fact that there are black lives
matter individuals involved in this as
well so we need to take a tough stance
and law enforcement we need to start
using force against individuals who are
out here burning people's property and
putting people's lives at danger and
then we also need to have the rhetoric
from President Trump and other quality
leaders who are saying enough
enough we're gonna deal with police
brutality but this is not the way to do
it you know you mentioned the political
leaders and it's like well Minnesota and
Minneapolis everyone involved every
public official is a Democrat every
public official is a Democrat this thing
has nothing to do with Trump doesn't
mean that Trump's reaction has been
perfect that's a separate issue but
every time this happens in one of these
cities in Atlanta in Ferguson wherever
might be we find out that they're
Democrat run cities so to that end or
when you hear de Blasio in New York City
who doesn't you know he lets criminals
out of jail and then tells them that
you're you know if you jump turnstiles
you won't even get a citation or
anything like that do you think in many
ways the ship has already sailed like
how can they reset it you know I've
talked to some people at the NYPD over
the last couple months they've had it
with the leadership but I think they
don't exactly know what to do because
you know they are civil servants still
but they know that their leaders are not
allowing them to restore law and order
yeah I think the citizens are waking up
man even with the Koch kovat epidemic
and I'll let going on you can see most
of the liberal mayor's the liberal
governors they want people shut down
forever they don't want you to ever work
again they want you to be they want to
destroy your businesses and people were
able to see that with Kovac and now you
look at the cities that are getting
burned down these liberal mayors and
governors won't even contest these
individuals people's businesses are
getting burned to the ground they're
never coming back the reputation of the
city is completely tarnished they're
willing to put you in jail for not
wearing a mask or not social distancing
but they're letting people go have a
free-for-all and I'll tell you this the
governor of Minnesota came out and then
literally poked the bear the black
community was making statements about
how oh this is unjust and everything
like that got people riled up and didn't
want to hit the fan they're not here to
protect the citizens the law-abiding
citizens so people are watching this
unfold and that's why myself you others
Candace Owens you know Larry elder a lot
of other people that I know who are
focused on facts are able to wake these
people up I get so many messages a day
saying thank God you exist thank God I
never thought of this was for but like
we are here to wake people up
the truth not Democrat not Republican
not black not white but waking people up
to the truth of what's going on and the
citizens will turn first and that's when
everything will unravel and we'll have
justice and we'll have equality I think
outside of this democratic run situation
so speaking of a democratic run
situation last time we did this you were
here in my studio in my home here in Los
Angeles so right now I was just scanning
Twitter before I started chatting with
you and I can see activists antiph on
black lives matter activists talking
about which neighborhoods to go to
depending on whether they're they have
immigrants there or it's more heavily
black or more heavily white or the rest
of it what should law enforcement be
doing right now I mean we know as 7:00
o'clock rolls around and it gets darker
even if there's a curfew we know what's
gonna most likely happen tonight it's
gonna be the same thing that happened
last night what should they be do I mean
what if you're an officer or you're the
you're the head of the LAPD what what
should you be doing right now it's time
to take a strong stance I said this on
the news earlier or it was a couple days
ago that America is acting like a parent
with a kid that's out of control and you
just let them run wow you already talked
to them you already put them in timeout
and now it's time to get a whuppin you
know we've already told them if they
need to stop we already people have been
arrested if you keep doing this you're
gonna have to be met with force and if I
was the head of LAPD or any chief in any
one of these cities you have to be met
with force
you're not gonna damage property people
are paying tax dollars for police to
protect property and protect life you
come out here and you try to burn down
buildings you're gonna get me a tree
force and all the way from minimal force
taser pepper ball a beanbag gun all the
way to deadly force if we do that force
continuum I guarantee you people will
not be stealing from Louie Vuitton and
going through the city ravaging the city
turning up homeless camps it will not
happen the police department has to be
strong you keep taking a weak stance
they're gonna take advantage of us
it's part of the fear there that the
police officers
or the administrators whoever the mayor
whoever it is they know that if they
take that straw let's say tonight they
were like are we're taking the stronger
stance tonight they know that causes a
spike that then causes the media to go
more crazy that then instigates a new
wave of it that that in many ways their
acquiescence is exactly what has led to
this this situation that now seems like
violence is the only thing that's gonna
end it yeah and I get that I understand
I mean we we had to have these
conversations at the University of
Arizona when I was a police in Tucson
because after they win the Final Four
and they want to protest and burn down
the city so we I've had these
conversations before but like I said I
keep liking it to a child if you keep
just pandering and saying oh I don't
want to spank in the day it's gonna make
you more upset you got it you got to be
strong first and they'll react to it
there's gonna be some fallout there may
be a couple people that lose their lives
but at some point we have to take a
strong stance as a country as a
law-enforcement agency so we can be
respected people are gonna hate police
no matter what and this is one problem
that I have
sometimes with Trump and sometimes I
have with it with the Republican
administration is that stop worrying
about what people who hate you gonna are
gonna think about you they're gonna hate
you if you do nothing they're gonna hate
you if you take a strong stance they're
gonna hate you if you're right so just
do what's right and don't worry about
what the naysayers say did you happen to
catch Van Jones his comment in the last
couple days where he said what America
has to fear more is the white Hillary
voting liberals did you catch that by
chance yeah I saw I saw a clip of that
which is one of the many things he said
so yeah so what do you make of just the
general concept thereof that much of
this is sort of guilty white liberals
and now I know we're not identity
politics guys so of course I'm not I'm
not condoning everything he's saying and
I don't think you can lump white people
together the same way you can't love
black people together but but the
general idea let's remove color even
that it's sort of the guilty liberals
who in many ways feed the fed feed the
fire that then ends up destroying black
communities yeah it's too guilty
liberals that are white and black
because you have all these black leaves
pushing the same agenda
you have white leaders push on the same
agenda I mean listen the liberal mindset
and I'm honestly wonder if it's a mental
problem like if it's a mental illness
I'm being honest like why is it
reasonable to not be rational I just I
just don't understand 40s 50 something
genders everybody can do whatever they
want to do live whatever life you want
to live they claim that the police are
the evil ones but then they don't want
you to have a rifle or have a gun to
protect yourself I mean they want to let
criminals go in bombard the city and do
whatever they want to do but if you
allow by the citizen you should be
punished they want you to wear masks but
then they then they allow people to not
social distance because it's for the
right cause these are people who are
illogical amongst us and it's destroying
our country in these same mentally
adverse individuals are the ones that
have socialism communism the countries
are destroyed over and it's not just a
color it's a mentality because there's
black and white people that are doing
the same thing and there's black and
white people who are on the side of
saying let's wake up to this man
let's stop hating each other let's stop
the the division let's stop lying about
racism in this country let's stop
talking about slavery and talking about
Jim Crow let's start thinking logically
and working together as brothers and
sisters in this country to make it
better but these liberal people I don't
know what it is man is it I don't know
if it's just that they want power more
than they care about people and they're
willing to say and do whatever to get to
that point honestly I can tell you what
I think it is which I think most of it's
just lazy thinking they don't want to
think about these issues hard so they
think if they kind of feel that
something sort of right they think that
that that makes it right I've seen so
many examples of this in the last couple
days where you can get these people to
flip the positions that they held three
months ago so there was a there was a
tweet that i retweeted from somebody who
said he's in a he's in an LA whatsapp
group like a community whatsapp group
and the woman who set up the community
was originally set up so that it
they could get guns out of their
community and now she's in there
screaming in all caps how can we get you
know security guards with guns to be
watching our streets and it's like well
you guys take whatever position you need
to take on any given moment so when you
call it sort of like a mental condition
I mean I always call it it's like a mind
virus you can if they don't have a they
don't have a principled stand they just
have Oh like I kind of feel like
something and then and that's a scary
place to be right I mean you can get
people to do almost anything yeah I mean
the saying goes that if you don't stand
for something you'll fall for anything
if you are living off your emotions your
emotions change you know and they become
hypocritical and there are people in our
society that operate with facts I don't
know if it's from birth I don't know if
it you're just more susceptible to think
with facts and and be logical I don't
know what it is Dave and I'm afraid that
if we don't start calling this stuff out
the good people are the people who are
strong-minded we're gonna be overrun by
these lunatics because they are willing
to go all the way out and some of us who
are rational and logical we're not I'm
not willing to go out and protest and
burn down buildings for because I don't
like the Cova 19 response that's my last
resort
that's after I've gone to the
legislature that's after I've complained
to the governor that's after I have been
peaceful for a significant amount of
time I'm not willing to go and burn down
places and kill people
over over emotions and in these are
things that I believe the strongman has
to stand up for and white people and I
don't want I don't mean to play identity
politics but we need to start keeping it
100 why people need to start being
bolder and more brave and standing up
against the lies against white the white
privilege police brutality
all white people are bad you're born
with silver spoons you you you are
oppressing a black man listen systemic
oppression systemic injustice it's clear
racism like how are you saying that
every judge is somehow races against
black people that that is asinine to
even make a statement like that when you
when you don't have any variables
cannot say that this judge in this
county with this prosecutor with this
juror
you know this jury pool convicted a
white man this way and then turn around
and convicted a black man this way
they're not making a one-to-one
comparison they're talking about someone
in LA
then I talking about somebody in Georgia
with total different laws total
different judges different demographics
different different backgrounds
different history different mitigating
and aggravating circumstances I just I
just don't get it in and out and I'm
getting frustrated and upset because we
need to start standing up just like
Donald Trump I'm sick and tired of
watching the left send everybody to
prison there's indictments every time I
turn around for people on the right
they're condemning them they call them a
races on TV but then you see Don Lemon
calling people like myself sellouts and
Negros and nothing happens with him you
see Hillary Clinton clearly breaking the
law she should be in prison for what she
did nothing happens to them
all of this investigation of pizza and
all kind of other stuff and know what
nothing happens to them
it's because we just sit on the
sidelines we're gonna have to start
stepping up and fighting back so with
that in mind then and watching you know
you're saying you're getting emails from
all sorts of people and I hear it all
the time too that people are waking up
to this stuff and it's it it's hard to
see right it's like you're watching a
city burn and it's like oh man are there
enough of these people who knows but but
we're laying the seeds when when you
heard the Biden comments from a week or
ten days ago
you ain't black if you ain't voting for
me or whatever whatever the exact quote
was in many ways did that just sort of
sum up almost everything that you've
been fighting against for these last
couple of years yeah I mean he put the
icing on the cake I don't know if you
realized it or not I don't even know
where he was at at the time but I mean
that is exactly what I believe the
Democratic Party and a leftist ideology
that's how they feel about black people
like you can't think for yourself how
dare you I can take away your your
ethnicity I could take away your value
if you don't vote for me
although I've been in office for thirty
plus years and I've done nothing for you
but put black people behind bars
bragging about the 94 crime bill doing
nothing they these politicians have done
nothing on both sides but if you don't
vote for me
you ain't black and he didn't just say
you are not black like he talks to white
people and other individuals he say you
ain't black like he's suggesting that
all black people are the same and that
we're gonna listen to your urban slang
and we're gonna somehow fall in line the
Democrats have been doing this from the
beginning
they have never changed Jim Crow slavery
the KKK it has never changed it went
from a physical bondage to a
psychological bondage and and there are
people unfortunately that fall for it
because there are people that stood up
for Joe Biden they defended Joe Biden
and they said it was a joke they said
all these other things and that is
exactly what individuals used to do
during the slave time where they had a
good with the master and they felt like
they were doing really well and they
wanted to hold the other black people
back on a plantation they didn't want
them to be free they didn't want them to
go out and explore and that's what these
Democratic Talking Heads are doing so
good
good faith the black people who just
want something to change in their
communities yeah and by the way it's not
just the Talking Heads because I'm sure
you've seen the same tweets I have from
celebrities black white and every other
color who are you know they're egging it
on while at the same time you know the
car db1 she's basically egging this
thing on and then somebody posted it's
like she's got a bowling alley in her
house I'm pretty sure she's gonna be
okay pretty sure she's got a fence
pretty sure she's got security guards
and I wonder if they were burning down
her Whole Foods where she probably sends
her employees to shop for her if maybe
she'd have be singing a different tune
you think oh you know they would you
know these people are fake
they're are disingenuous I mean these
people I don't know like I'm saying I
don't know if it's intentional or these
people are having a mental breakdown I
mean cardi B brags about drugging people
and robbing people a lot of these
celebrities are celebrating criminals
they're celebrating rappers who spent
their whole life selling drugs beating
people up
shooting people and they're celebrating
these very same people and then when a
young man like Tyshawn Lee people may
not know who he is a young man in
Chicago he was nine years old got shot
up by two gang members they put
cigarette butts out on him when somebody
like Tyshawn Lee passes away or a nine
year old get him killed in an in a
drive-by shooting or a young lady during
a school where it gets shot through the
window because of knuckleheads out there
killing people where are these people
where are the celebrities Chicago had
the worst weekend since 2015 and I
remember why they stopped at 2015
because before 2015 they had 82
shootings and 14 homicides so and that's
just one weekend where are the
celebrities where is LeBron James where
is Colin Kapernick he's not in Minnesota
protesting he's not doing anything the
only meaning are kneeling that Colin
Kaepernick is doing is probably the
kneel down to pick up his Louie Vuitton
bag that he didn't purchase from that
huge million dollar Nike deal these
people are faith day they don't have no
integrity they have they have nothing
they're just they're just aimless almost
soulless shells walking around virtue
signaling do we have any other ideas on
how to keep breaking the the paradigm
then I mean I've been doing an
incredible job of it but anything else
that we can do besides facts and being
decent and trying to be upstanding
citizens and the rest of it nah man I
think it's it comes down to education it
comes down to love you know sometimes
you got to do some tough love in there
but sometimes you do have to be
empathetic and you have to know your
audience man like if you're talking to a
friend that you love and that you care
about and y'all know each other then you
can be you can have a softer approach
you could talk to them sending videos
and send them encouragement and remain a
loving decent friend and then when you
have people who they don't care about
you they hate you your Uncle Tom sellout
a fool or racist then you can hit them
with the hard facts and you can just
keep pushing it because everything
starts in here everything even I know
there's people that don't believe in God
and there is a concept that I believe
that is reasonable is the secret you
know the book the secret
it starts up here I read it you can
manifest what you become in your mind
you can manifest your destiny and I
think it's associated the Bible too
because the Bible talks about
manifesting and speaking life and death
and power the power of life and death is
in your tongue but you can speak things
into existence so if in your mind you're
being told that the white man is against
you racism is destroying America you
can't ever go here or there without the
white man the country is bad you your
country will be bad to you you will
begin to fulfill the prophecy that you
said in your mind but if you begin to
hear the truth and the truth is in your
heart and you begin to understand logic
and reason and you hear the truth about
America how America is the greatest
country on planet earth how America is
the least racist place you're gonna
you're gonna ever exist in this
dispensation of time how America gives
you the opportunity to become whatever
you want you can start from zero and
become a billionaire when those things
are implemented in your mind perpetuated
like great human beings like you and I
then people will begin to change an
atmosphere will begin to be created and
we will see less of this evilness hatred
dysfunction and we'll see more people
coming out of this thing being
victorious and uniting as a as an
American front you know I should let you
go there because it was it was a
beautiful ending but I do have one more
for you and I also want to mention that
everything that you said there you know
I spent a year and a half on tour with
Jordan Peterson and one of the things
that he would push almost every single
night of the tour was that if you just
told the truth the amount of Correction
that you could put into the world would
be unimaginable and I think that really
is what you're saying there so I do have
one more for you though because I think
this is where a lot of people that are
that are maybe disaffected lefties or
confused liberals or whatever that is
but they're waking up and they're
suddenly going oh maybe the police can't
protect me the way I thought or or all
of the things that we're all thinking
right now I know you're also a big
Second Amendment advocate obviously can
you just talk a little bit about how
people should not be afraid of guns and
maybe should be willing to take a little
more responsibility for
the security of themselves their
property and their family because I
think there is I think that's the next
growing movement right now is all the
lefties who thought they'd always be
safe in Beverly Hills who suddenly are
watching it burn I mean quite literally
right now and going oh well maybe I do
have to protect myself yeah I mean this
is a free
I don't know 90 day trial took communism
and it's also a 90 day trial to a second
amendment class I mean if you just have
been existing in America you could have
you could have dropped off another
planet you have come to America you're
gonna realize that socialism and
communism and the stuff that the left is
pushing it is something that nobody
wants and then you're also gonna realize
that you probably should carry a firearm
to defend yourself because this is
something that I've been telling people
for years as a former police officer I
understand that cops cannot be
teleporting everywhere to save you they
we don't eat we're is another another
call somebody breaks in your house you
have to then call 9-1-1 and you know the
process it takes minutes and your life
can be lost or saved in seconds people
should stop all of the belief in the
media in the in the ar-15s and a big
boogeyman and start realizing what the
Founding Fathers were thinking when they
implement it your second Amendment and
people should realize this as well guns
don't have to be a scary thing go to a
gun range
get your CCW license shoot at the
firearms range because you are getting a
front row seat so if you do nothing and
you sit back with your hands up and hope
to god that the police gonna show up to
your mansion you're gonna end up in a
bad position you're gonna end up with
your hands up and your pants down and I
don't want to live like that and I don't
want other people to so listen to people
who are logical like myself and others
who are telling you and then one of you
for years go and get yourself personal
protection firearms if it's a shotgun if
it's a handgun if it's an AR I have all
of them get those for your household
because it's not you know
just the looters that you have to worry
about it's not just the criminals that
you have to worry about you should have
those protections in case there's a
problem with foreign entities coming
into our country terrorism coming into
our country all of those things you can
assure your protection if you just
adhere to the Second Amendment Brandon I
got to tell you everyone always asks me
when I get interviewed they say what's
your favorite type of guest and I always
it's so obvious to me it's the type of
people that are clearly just doing what
they're supposed to be doing I don't
know that there's a better example than
you because you are just doing what
you're supposed to be doing I know you
got a million things to do thanks for
joining us it's at officer Tatum on
Twitter and we'll tag in and all that
good stuff and just keep it up man
please thanks Dave thanks for having me
on man I love you brother
and I'll see you the next time if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell